director John Singleton has died I got
nominated for an Emmy I guess I got to
take this directing stuff seriously
et can confirm that the Emmy and Oscar
nominated director was taken off of life
support on Monday after suffering a
stroke earlier on April 17th the 51 year
old grew up in South Central LA and
graduated from USC School of Cinematic
Arts singleton became the youngest
director and first african-american
writer director nominated for an Academy
Award for his film debut boys in the
hood Los Angeles drugs just the fact
that the film is really still relevant
today and you know I'm honored to you
know have been a part of it and you know
it was really my graduate thesis script
but you may see and you know the part of
history and you know there's many more
films to do to be men you know started
my career his groundbreaking look at
South Central LA star Cuba Gooding jr.
Angela Bassett Laurence Fishburne Regina
King and Ice Cube Singleton's credits
also include too fast too furious
the People vs OJ Simpson billions and
Empire it is what it is that people
versus OJ Simpson it's it's the story
that America is constantly intrigued
with his latest project snowfall was
renewed for season 3 on FX last year
singleton is survived by his mother
Sheila father Danny and his five
children